mr. Hughes someone is making a profit on
the plane that can't fly this plane will
fly if it were to be a failure I would
leave this country and never come back
and I mean it not millionaire and what
the hell happened to the closeup of me
in the cockpit
roll film remember any driver who tries
any hanky-panky with a contract
actresses fire I am I'm Frank two weeks
in Los Angeles and you're working for
Howard Hughes no harm having high hopes
family and what church you go to Crane
First Methodist in Fresno I forgive you
she's giving we're Baptists do you know
why Baptist think sex is bad no yeah cuz
it might lead to dancing when is Frank's
fiance coming to town she believes that
once you've been intimate and the eyes
of God you're committed to that person
for the rest of your life
I agree with Sarah well that's I mean
that's a little I'm not legally married
mr. Hughes I'd like to thank you for the
chance to become a star you've never had
a drink in your life
I don't drink maybe I'm not the right
girl for this a movie actress should
have big bosoms and be sexy I mean in
this town aren't those the rules
you're an exception the rules don't
apply to you my friend I was terribly
you think I'm nuts right get that person
out of here I think you should see
someone when you told me the rules don't
apply to me you know they don't apply to
you either he said the rules don't apply
ivz and I'm not some disgusting heat of
a virgin trying to steal another woman's
husband you know mr. Hughes wants to see
you
well hello
that's Marlon mabry Patel is she doing
here you said you wanted to grow up with
the two ends
yes Marilyn Monroe have you heard from
people that I'm crazy all right come on
come on
if what you are is crazy then give me
more crazy you make an old guy
courageous Marlon did somebody give that
to you she's hit the jackpot
you ain't seen nothing yet did just
saved everyone people call you a hero I
don't feel like a hero there's been too
much talking to press already I'm
overwhelmed by all this attention the
left engine was